JONATHAN: to this week's
office hours.
I'm joined by Wolff Dobson.
My name is Jonathan Beri.
And our guests today are Gerwin
and Sigfried, some guys
you may have seen before.
Hey, guys.
GERWIN: Hi.
SIEGFRIED: Hi.
JONATHAN: So if you've been
following our blog, our Plus
pages, our own stream, you know
that we released Google+
[? ingrown ?] apps.
GERWIN: Yay.
JONATHAN: General--
Yes.
But today's topic, we will be
talking about what we released
to developers, some new end
user features and any
questions that we have from
our guests, as well as the
original announcement plus
those this morning.
So if you have questions, and
you're watching live stream,
go ahead and ask it there.
Before we go into the technical
piece about the
features being launched, we
will say that it's being
released slowly over
the course today.
So if you don't see anything in
apps in your hangouts yet,
you will by the end
of the day.
Cool, so let's start with
our new developer site.
So we--
WOLFF: Well, actually, I think
we should start with apps.
JONATHAN: Our apps.
WOLFF: Our guests, have you
guys seen the new app
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and everything.
SIEGFRIED: Not live yet.
WOLFF: Not yet.
Yeah, I noticed we don't
have it here.
As Jonathan said, we're
rolling it out slowly.
It's pretty neat.
We've got [? topher ?]
on there.
We've got some shared
collaboration
stuff like slide share.
JONATHAN: Thank you.
WOLFF: So yeah, a lot
of new partners.
I really hope everybody has
a chance to play with it.
JONATHAN: Yes, there are
some photos in the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So you can see it.
WOLFF: Yeah, so take a look.
Take a look under
[? the development tool. ?]
JONATHAN: So for the end user
features, we now have the
ability to take from an app of
one of our feature partners to
go back to any recently used
apps, an ability to toggle on
and off apps and a new feature
which we added.
It's called Extensions, and
we're going to go into that a
little bit.
WOLFF: We're going to talk
about what those are.
JONATHAN: But those are
different ways to interact.
And of course, the other
end user feature is the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] button, which
we're going to go into how to
make and how to use in your
site a little later.
So the general workflow is
somebody would like to use an
app, a hangout, and there's an
app in it, you can certainly
use the application together.
Or you can launch a hangout
button on your site and go
right to the app.
WOLFF: We have examples of that
in the [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So first thing obviously,
we have some pictures of
collaborating together.
We have a picture of the first
extension, which is the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] tab.
But what I'd like to talk about
right now is one of the
big features is you
can now shift your
hangout apps from public.
And we want to talk about
how you do that.
So why don't you click on
Publishing Apps right now.
Or should we start with--?
JONATHAN: Let's just
[INAUDIBLE].
WOLFF: Well, click on Publishing
Apps to make sure I
[INAUDIBLE] here.
Yeah, let's just go
there [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN: Great.
WOLFF: So if you go to--
so Create A New
Hangout App, please.
JONATHAN: Hangout app.
WOLFF: [INAUDIBLE] awesome.
Then go ahead and throw in
hangouts, what you always do.
Now, go click on Hangouts.
And when you look into Hangouts,
you have a lot of
new [? features. ?]
And you can see those
now, I believe.
So of you scroll down a little
bit, the first section there
is just where [INAUDIBLE].
We [? do ?] you a section where
it shows you the title
of your apps, and that's
the move here in the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
It's also in the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
while you're loading.
So take something nice
besides hangout app.
Now, the next section there,
is your hangout
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] an extension?
And it goes into a little bit
more detail there, but it's
basically an app that appears in
the leftmost 300 pixels of
your screen.
So we've released a single
extension so far, which will
be the Fx app, which allows
you to have more elaborate
decorations.
But the idea is that it's
for something for
[? trying out ?], people
cracking dice in a role
playing game.
JONATHAN: Like a note-taking
app.
WOLFF: Yeah, something
like that.
It basically takes the place
where the testing
[? moment is. ?]
If you check extension and you
weren't in Dev console, it
will look like a regular app
right now because we don't yet
have an extension pane
in the hangout.
But it's OK, because once you
go public, it actually will
appear in the extension place.
JONATHAN: So that's actually
an important thing to note.
Right now, the apps and the
extensions, from an API point
of view, are the same.
And so all the APIs that you
have within an app, you have
within your extension.
WOLFF: And the shared state--
if two people are running that
extension, that will be
sharing state.
You can actually have two
apps running now.
You can have the extension and
the regular app, and the
extension will share
a state with other
extensions of the same kind.
So if two people are in the same
extension, they'll share
a state together.
JONATHAN: [INAUDIBLE]
WOLFF: And the main page app
will have shared state with
your other main page apps of
the same types, but they do
not communicate with
each other.
And in fact, you can't
even tell if one or
the other is running.
JONATHAN: Right.
So to sum it up, you can
actually have a hangout
without an app, with an app,
with an extension, and with an
app and an extension.
WOLFF: 0, 1, 11, and 0.
JONATHAN: There are those
who can count in binary.
WOLFF: And those who can't.
JONATHAN: Something.
WOLFF: There are ten
kinds of people.
There's [? import binary ?]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JONATHAN: That's it.
WOLFF: OK, so anyway, like I
said, if you click that right
now, it'll tell the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] server that
you want to share this
as an extension.
It will have no effect when
you're in what we're calling
developer sandbox, which is
[? hanging out with ?]
the API to talk [INAUDIBLE].
If you're running against
production, which is
+.google.com/hangouts, then it
will appear as an extension.
However, you can't run it
against production unless you
publish it.
So let's talk about
publishing.
JONATHAN: One more thing about
extensions before we move on.
When you flip that bit, the only
thing that does change is
the size the icons that
are required.
So if you notice that--
if our machine would match up.
There you go.
It's a different size because
it's where we place the
extension launcher.
WOLFF: Yeah, the extension
launcher is more on the top
bar where the little dog face
and everything were before,
and then the apps actually
run in the base.
So yeah, Jonathan's
going to show you.
JONATHAN: So this is a screen
shot of what it looks like.
WOLFF: Give them
one more take.
So if you look here next to
screen share, there's a little
icon there.
That's what extensions are.
When you click that, it's going
to show an extension.
That's where the icon
is going to be.
We do provide a default icon,
but it's not nearly as cool as
the icon you can pick out.
So you should definitely
put your own icons up.
And actually, go back and
show the apps up here.
JONATHAN: Oh, yes.
WOLFF: So if you go
down and look at--
JONATHAN: Do we have a screen
shot of the App switcher?
WOLFF: Well anyway, in the
App switcher, you'll
see this big grid.
Probably,
[? you're not running that. ?]
Go down.
Nope.
Sorry, it's in the
[? Public here. ?]
This is my last offer.
JONATHAN: Some of this was
written very recently.
JONATHAN: Possibly
the last minute.
So right, so scroll
up a little bit.
That's a picture of the App
switcher right there.
That's where your icons
are going to appear.
It looks like the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] when you
mouse over it.
And the thing goes up and
down to show your
description, very cool.
JONATHAN: And this grid that
we actually mention here is
the selector, [? cursor ?]
feature and most
recently used as well.
We don't have a screen
shot for you.
WOLFF: OK, so going back
to the console.
So anyway, put URLs to
your icons there.
If you put bogus URLs in,
then it will just put
the defaults there.
So again, be cool.
The black and white one
is for mouse down.
Application description,
right.
So the application description
will appear.
If you've ever been to the
current web store, you have
those little squares.
When you mouse over them, a
little white thing goes up and
says, I want to use this app.
And then there's a little
one-sentence description.
Again, feel free to sell you
app in there, make it look
like it's fun to use.
JONATHAN: By selling, make
people want to install it.
WOLFF: Yes, exactly.
Then down in Support, you need
a terms of service you need a
privacy policy, and you
need some way for
Google to contact you.
JONATHAN: And these
are all URLs.
Emails are not sufficient.
And I think Gerwin had a
question before we started
about terms of service
and privacy policy.
GERWIN: Yes.
JONATHAN: And so the best
answer I can give you is
because we can't provide Google
service, terms of
service and privacy policy vary
from country to country.
And also, depending on
the industry, how you
want to word that.
So if you're going to publish
an app, you should have your
terms of service and privacy
policy reviewed by somebody
who will provide Google
authority for the countries
you want to operate in.
GERWIN: OK.
JONATHAN: Outside of that,
anything I say is just
conjecture and what I observe.
Just make sure, especially on
the privacy policy, which I
care more about-- maybe less for
the legal-- is be upfront
with your users.
So what you do with their data
is very important, and make
sure they know what you're
doing with their data.
How legalese you want to make
it, that's really up to you
and your legalese.
WOLFF: But you need to tell them
what you're going to do,
and that's what we're
looking for.
So [UNINTELLIGIBLE] contact,
we want [? a page. ?]
Hopefully, it'll have email or
a way to post or [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN: Even something as
simple as your + page-- if you
feel that's the right way for
them to contact you-- if we
create a + page for you app,
that could be sufficient.
JONATHAN: Make a + page
for your app.
Lastly, you have this
check box here,
which is Make Public.
And Make Public says make
your application
available to all users.
If this box is unchecked, it's
going to work the way it has
worked in Developer
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] until now,
which is only people who are
in your Teams list--
up there on the left--
only people on your Teams list
are going to be able to see
the app at all.
They are the only people who
know that it exists.
If you try to bring somebody
in, they won't be able to
install it.
If you click Make Public,
everybody in the world, if
they have your product ID, which
is that number up in the
thing, if they have their
product ID, they'll
be able to run it.
And keep that in mind.
We ask you to make two steps.
The first is that you make
a [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
ID because as you will notice
when you are running outside
of [UNINTELLIGIBLE]--
actually, if you've created an
[? planet ID ?] for your app,
Google will now ask you, when
you begin running the app, for
permission.
Actually, a permission
box pops up before
the app begins running.
And it asks for exactly
three strokes.
There are two hangout strokes
that are basically--
this app may or may not
use your camera.
One of them is Plus Me.
Google needs to know
who you are.
Or rather, the app is going
to know who you are.
And the last one is
more [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN: Yes, that's correct.
WOLFF: So anyway, it'll
ask for these strokes.
Those three strokes actually
mean that you are now
authenticated, which means if
you used the authentication
sample that I [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
a while back, which is now
[INAUDIBLE], you'll be able to
get a token without actually
popping up a box, which
is pretty neat.
JONATHAN: So that means that
the JavaScript client, the
Google API JavaScript client,
which is in alpha still, you
can actually use that within
a hangout to call [? OA ?]
endpoints for all
the Google APIs.
WOLFF: You can get a [? OA2 ?]
client access hookup.
[INAUDIBLE].
And that's big.
That means that it's built
into the apps.
It's making upfront to the user
what you're going to be
doing in your app.
It's pretty cool.
JONATHAN: That's the first
requirement form.
WOLFF: First step is that
you go and you click
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
GERWIN: Yeah, so can I ask
just a short question?
WOLFF: Sure.
GERWIN: So usually, when you
make a client, you have to
provide the callback URL and
admit its sources for the
JavaScript.
Is there something special you
have to take care of when you
want to use the client ID for
the hangout apps, or do you
take care of this yourself?
WOLFF: That's a great
question.
I'll repeat it.
So the question is, what's a
callback URL for a client ID
that's running inside
a hangout?
Is that right?
GERWIN: Yes, exactly.
WOLFF: And the answer is, you
don't have to fill that out.
GERWIN: OK.
WOLFF: You can just leave it
as example.com, as long as
you're running it at hangout.
And the reason for
that is because--
well, it's long-winded--
but basically, the gadget server
knows that you are
running the authenticated
service inside this I-frame
and will take care of the
redirect for you.
GERWIN: OK, perfect.
WOLFF: It's also why you, as
we'll discover in the Docs,
actually don't need to send in
your APIP because again, the
gadget server and the RPC
services will re-write your
client ID because it knows
exactly who you are because
you're already [? authorized. ?]
We know who you are.
JONATHAN: By doing the
rewriting, we can keep it
secure without--
WOLFF: Yes, it means people
again aren't reading your
client ID off your page.
JONATHAN: Exactly.
WOLFF: It's win.
So again, that's all
you have to do.
You just have to type in your
project name and that's what's
going to appear in the pop-up.
And you can provide your
pictures and stuff if you go
back-- oh, you missed
[INAUDIBLE].
Oh, there we go.
Right, if you put your product
logo and your product name,
then that's what's going to
pop up in the in the OAuth
dialogue, but all you
really have to do is
have a produce table.
I mean we encourage product
logos, but cool.
And then here, just pick
Web Application and hit
[? Great Plan ID. ?]
You don't have to worry about
the redirect URI or the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
GERWIN: OK perfect.
WOLFF: Then go back.
So now, he's created
a client ID.
Last thin you have to do--
and this guy has already
done it.
Last thing we ask, if you're
going to make an app public,
we want you to register as a
Chrome Web Store developer
JONATHAN: And so you only
have to do this once.
WOLFF: Yes, only once, and you
actually don't have to upload
anything directly to the
Chrome web store.
All we ask is that you
register as a Chrome developer.
JONATHAN: And if you've
registered in the past, you
don't have to register again.
WOLFF: Yes.
If you've already verified,
you're verified.
It's fine.
What we need you to do, there's
a link off the page in
the cases where you
do have it.
Follow that link.
Say yes, I want to sign up.
Then go to this dashboard page,
and if you've never
verified before, the
verification is a $5 fee.
JONATHAN: I think in
most countries.
WOLFF: At least in the
United States.
In Mountain View, it's $5, which
is just a one time fee
to make sure that you are who
you say you are, more or less.
And after that, you
can publish as
many apps as you want.
And only one developer on your
team needs to be a Chrome web
store-verified person.
And to emphasize again, you
only need to be a verified
Chrome developer if you
plan to go public.
JONATHAN: Yes.
WOLFF: If you don't want to go
public, don't need to do it.
JONATHAN: So if you're a
university student, and you're
working on this for a project,
you may not have to even worry
about the--
WOLFF: Yes, you won't have to
worry about that unless you
want to make it public.
If you're just doing a demo or
a hackathon, that's fine.
So after that, hit Save, and
then, you will get a--
JONATHAN: I don't have
any content.
WOLFF: You don't have an HML.
And then you'll get your Enter
Hangout [? lid. ?]
Now go back.
Do you have an app
open on there?
[INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN: Oh yeah, I do.
WOLFF: Yeah, just get it back.
And I'm going to talk a little
bit about that URL because
this is also exciting.
So if you look, that Enter
Hangout [? lid ?]
links to Hangouts API, to [?
hangoutsapi.bandit.google.com
?] or something a
lot like that.
And that goes to the
sandbox server.
And we talked about
this before.
The production server is
plus.google.com/hangouts.
Even after you make it public,
this will still go to the
development server.
You have to construct the URL
yourself to get to the--
JONATHAN: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
WOLFF: Right.
And then can you show
an example of the--
well, we'll do it on
the other page.
So great.
So there you go.
So that's what you need to know
about the new Dev console.
If you get invalid input, which
will appear at the top
if you get some of your stuff
wrong, which means that some
of your fields aren't exactly
the way it was in [? Forms. ?]
Also, one last thing.
Let's say you have an app that's
public, and you don't
want it to be public anymore.
Anybody who has ownership
rights may unclick that
rights, whether or not
they're a registered,
verified Chrome developer.
However, only registered Chrome
developers can make it
back public again.
JONATHAN: So some of the reasons
why you'd want to
remove the public feature
of your app.
If there's an issue, and it's
affecting all users, and you
can't push it live is a reason
you would take it down.
This is one reason.
If there's some content issue
or issues such as user
complaints, you'd want to
take that down as well.
So take advantage of that
feature in those instances.
WOLFF: Or you just
want to retool.
You have a more awesome idea.
Then the last thing is about--
shoot, I can't remember where
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] is.
Oh, right, and as usually, if
you try to go to a hangout
app, and it's not public, and
you aren't a member of that
team on production--
if you go to a hangout app on
production that's not public,
it just won't let you.
And you'll just be in
a regular hangout.
JONATHAN: This is true.
WOLFF: Now you know.
JONATHAN: So we went over--
WOLFF: The new Dev console.
JONATHAN: We went over the new
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] or end users
the new Dev console.
WOLFF: Also to talk about is--
JONATHAN: We talked about
[? OA ?] a little bit.
WOLFF: Yeah.
We basically went through--
oh, let's talk about
extensions.
JONATHAN: Oh, extensions,
great.
WOLFF: So, going to
the sample apps.
JONATHAN: Sample apps.
WOLFF: OK, so actually, I'm
going to interrupt and talk
about buttons for
just a second.
You notice on this page,
we now have this
cool red hangout button?
That--
hello, Gerwin, again.
That hangout, that button
is a link to
plus.google.com out here.
Let's go to buttons
real quick.
I need a button.
No, it's right there.
JONATHAN: Oh, sorry.
Maybe you should have
pushed the button.
WOLFF: Right, so we need your
app ID, which you get off of
the Dev console.
It's in the URL.
It's the Project
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
12 or 13 or 14, whatever
it is.
And basically, all you need
to do is attach it to
hangouts.api.tal
kgadget.google.com/hangouts.
That's going to go to
the sandbox server.
And when you want to
release, you go to
plus.google.com/hangouts.
We give you example buttons
in four exciting sizes.
We absolutely encourage
you to use these.
The images themselves are served
off of plus.google.com,
so they're actually
[INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN: Yeah, so if there's
ever a change or an issue,
that's the best way to get
the up to date button.
And also, we serve it off
of RCBN so it's faster.
WOLFF: It's going to
be super fast.
JONATHAN: Also if you notice,
some of the dimensions
height-wise line up with
some of our other
buttons and the badges.
So we can line them up.
WOLFF: So anyway, going back
to the sample apps.
So that's how you
make a button.
Please make buttons in
the sample apps.
So these are our sample
apps we have
previous to this launch.
However, if you go into simple
hangout app, that one is a new
one that I made, which is as
small a hangout app as I could
possibly make that still
did something.
JONATHAN: Want to view the
source real quickly?
WOLFF: Sure.
Go to simple hangout app.
There's not much to it.
We're going to go down,
and basically
there's some styling.
And there's a button, and
there's a thing that when you
press the button, it tells
you who's in the hangout.
It's not super exciting.
Oh shoot, we can't
run this because
you're running a hangout.
JONATHAN: Yes, we can't
run it [INAUDIBLE].
WOLFF: Ah, curses.
So darn, that ruins my
showing an exception.
JONATHAN: Isn't there
a screen shot?
WOLFF: Well, it's cool.
JONATHAN: OK.
WOLFF: There's a screen shot
in the docs, but people can
look that up.
So anyway, that is presented
as an extension.
However, if you download it
and serve it yourself and
don't check the extension box,
it will show up a main app.
JONATHAN: Yeah, so a good tip.
All the sample apps that
we have hosted
under a gadget XML--
in the past and moving
forward--
you can actually just take that
and pass it into a new
project, a new hangout app.
So you can just run
it and test it.
It's really good if you're
trying to show somebody really
quickly and you don't
have an app made.
And it's also a great way
to test without hosting.
WOLFF: It's also a great way to
test that you are correctly
starting a hangout if you're
having private connection
issues or something like that.
Wait, is my app broken,
or am I just
having connection problems?
So that's a great thing to do.
It's also just fun
to play with.
[INAUDIBLE].
OK, we talked about OA.
Can you go into Fact
real quickly?
JONATHAN: Yes.
WOLFF: We talked a little bit
about how do I get an access
to open, and do I have a link
to a hangout experiment that
will allow you to get an open.
That is experimental.
It's experimental for a number
of reasons, including that the
JSAPI is still in alpha.
JONATHAN: Yes.
WOLFF: But we do encourage you
to use it and tell us how it's
working for you.
JONATHAN: And I believe some
of the initial apps there
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Are actually using
that JS client.
So it is working.
It works well.
Just since you brought up the
Facts, we just started this
new Facts section for issues
that come up in Office Hours
and the forum.
So we might be adding more
and more really relevant
questions to this.
WOLFF: And actually brings us
to one of the new features.
We didn't--
JONATHAN: It's my favorite.
Aside from Launch, it's
my favorite feature.
WOLFF: Besides Launch, your
favorite feature.
If you're working with
media overlays.
So you're doing the
face tracking.
Can you make yourself a dog?
JONATHAN: Can I do dogs?
WOLFF: Wait, no.
You would have to
make us a dog.
If you're doing face tracking,
if you're doing overlays, up
until this--
[LAUGHS].
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
[? If you ever wanted to ?]
exhibiting being animals,
which is adorable, up until this
point, you have only been
able to do HTTP requests to get
those off of the server.
Now, you can actually
use a data URI.
JONATHAN: Yes.
WOLFF: We have an example of
the data URI, with the
smallest data URI I could find
that would still be coherent.
Follow that link.
It's so exciting.
I'm so proud of it.
It is a little tiny
green spot.
But anyway, that's an example.
But it can be really useful if
you're drawing something in a
canvas, and you want to rig it
up as an extension, or you're
having somebody recording
audio--
or downloading audio
and playing it--
and then you want to
just pull it off.
JONATHAN: Or if you just want
to reduce image size and not
actually have to download
images.
WOLFF: Yes.
JONATHAN: Pretty exciting.
WOLFF: Yeah, that's
really cool.
The demo that we did for South
by Southwest, where you draw
on your face and then it appears
on your thing, I
actually did that to a server
where I actually uploaded and
downloaded it.
Now, I can get rid of that stuff
and just make it so it
goes directly to your browser
in your feed.
JONATHAN: This opens
up a lot more
possibilities with [? data ?]
overlays.
WOLFF: Yeah, really
excited about what
people can do with overlays.
The other thing that we added,
which also concerns overlays--
and actually, this one is only
for people who have the
plug-in version 2.8 and above.
JONATHAN: 2.8.5 actually.
WOLFF: 2.8.5 and above.
Is that you can have multiple
overlays on.
So under the old scheme--
Gerwin's eyes lit up.
Under the old scheme,
you could only
have a single overlay.
Or if you played a sound through
that hangout, then it
would only play one.
It would cancel all your
other overlays.
Now, we support multiple
overlays.
I believe 2.8.5 is out
for Windows and Mac.
JONATHAN: That's correct.
Most Chrome users should
have that already.
It's also [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
off their Firefox.
WOLFF: Yeah, so way cool.
And in fact, our new Fx apps
extension that's going to be
in the app actually does have as
many overlays as you want.
JONATHAN: And the Fx app, it's
the cat dog overlay to the
next level, plus plus.
WOLFF: Yeah, plus [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN: So for users, if you
require the multiple overlays,
they'll be prompted
to upgrade, and it
should be going out.
[INAUDIBLE] there's
a way to check.
If your users complain about not
having it, they can got to
[INAUDIBLE].
WOLFF: And figure out whether
they've got the
right one or not.
JONATHAN: And [? debug. ?]
What else did we want
to cover today?
WOLFF: Actually, that's
all the new
features, which was a lot.
JONATHAN: It was like
a whirlwind.
WOLFF: A whirlwind tour.
We work right next
to each other.
JONATHAN: So I think first, I
want to start with Gerwin and
Siegfried if they have
any questions.
I know Gerwin already asked one,
but please let us know.
GERWIN: Actually, all my
questions have been answered.
Now, I'm going to have to play
with the new things, and there
will be more questions maybe.
JONATHAN: Awesome.
So we're expecting
a Hangout Disco?
WOLFF: Hangout Disco.
GERWIN: Yes.
JONATHAN: Awesome.
SIEGFRIED: I'm working on
the homepage already.
WOLFF: I hope you're
using new button.
JONATHAN: So Gerwin, I
haven't you seen you
go in Hangout Disco.
WOLFF: Well, now they'll
have the opportunity.
You can [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JONATHAN: It's exactly
what it sounds like.
WOLFF: It is a disco
in a hangout.
SIEGFRIED: In 3-D.
WOLFF: I also strongly
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
JONATHAN: Yes, Web GL.
Siegfried, any questions
from you?
SIEGFRIED: Yeah, I'm
waiting for updates
for the regular API.
I haven't tried hangouts yet,
but I will do it now, I think.
And yeah, I'm still playing with
the regular API, doing
some stuff with it.
And I'm waiting for [? access ?]
for more streams
and more not so public items
on the regular posts.
JONATHAN: Right, actually, I
saw your post. That's great
feedback, and Marie
communicated that.
And the answer for the general
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
API status is we're still
working on things.
And we don't have any
comment of when they
release, but we're--
WOLFF: Hey guys, we are not
close enough to the
microphones.
How are we doing?
Is this better?
JONATHAN: OK.
So we're going to up to the post
and see if there are any
questions that we can answer.
WOLFF: Actually, I'm looking
at the post right now, and
pretty much, there's
been a lot of,
yay, which is wonderful.
And complaining that--
you know what it is?
It's your fan being
picked up by the--
JONATHAN: Oh.
WOLFF: It's so noisy.
JONATHAN: I'm actually
going to drop out.
WOLFF: Yeah, why don't you
close your thing there.
Oh, create topic and
hangout title.
You're still able to set
the hangout title.
When you click on the Hangout
button, users get the ability
to set their topic.
Asking for I'd like
to set the topic--
JONATHAN: Programtically?
WOLFF: Programatically,
that's a cool idea.
That's cool.
We should look into that.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Actually questions have
been pretty much--
JONATHAN: I'm looking through
the original posting.
SIEGFRIED: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Can I just ask another
question?
I had always had the problem of
getting the right time of
the hangout because you're
announcing it in your time,
and I'm seeing it in my time
because I live in Germany.
So we have a difference of
eight or nine hours.
And it would be very cool if
there is a future in the
posting that you can surround
date and time with some
special characters and
they get converted
to the local time.
JONATHAN: Yeah, We
would be cool.
So that would be more of a
general product feature.
SIEGFRIED: Yeah.
WOLFF: Yeah, that's
a good idea.
JONATHAN: Like a macro
script kind of thing?
WOLFF: Or are you talking more
about having the locale
included with the post?
JONATHAN: No, I think the idea,
which is pretty cool, is
something that you would see in
a CNS system where you just
put time, and it would convert
it for each client for their
local time.
If I did 11:30 PST, it would
go to the German time zone
automatically.
It's a cool idea.
We'll definitely send
that back up.
So any more questions
from the stream?
WOLFF: No, I think we're
actually doing pretty well.
We're really excited to see what
kinds of things you guys
are building, and we would
absolutely love it if you sent
us public apps that
we can play with.
JONATHAN: Yeah, especially
on our plus pages.
We're start [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
them.
And back just to review, when
you're ready to go live, you
publish that app.
You can host the link inside
Google+ or any other social
media tool directly.
Of course, you could also use
the button and put it on the
site or anywhere that
hosts the HTML.
WOLFF: Some kind of
loading page.
JONATHAN: And yeah, that's how
you get your app around.
And one somebody uses your app,
they don't necessarily
have to go searching back for
that app again because we
service that in the Recently
Used tab inside the app.
WOLFF: Yeah, Recently Used.
Extensions do not appear
in Recently Used.
Extensions are, again,
designed to be more
personalized apps, so
do be aware of that.
JONATHAN: Of course, we have
our feedback channels.
So we have our Issue Tracker for
general Google= stuff, and
that's the best place to surface
issues with that
hangouts API or the
apps in general.
We have our forums
or questions and
answers type of posting.
And of course, you can follow
us at Google+ and ask us
questions directly there.
And I think we're waiting now
for you guys to make some
awesome apps.
SIEGFRIED: Concerning the
hangout button, is it possible
to share someone else's
hangout buttons?
For example, if Gerwin was
publishing his hangout and the
button, can I use that hangout
button on my site also.
JONATHAN: Yes, once an app is
published publicly, then it's
just a URL with--
WOLFF: It's [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
question mark, VID equals the
name of your product.
SIEGFRIED: OK.
JONATHAN: So anybody can
show that around.
So you can email that.
WOLFF: You can post
a gallery of apps,
whatever you want to do.
We'd love to see stuff
like that.
SIEGFRIED: Cool.
JONATHAN: So we want to create
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] on it, right?
And you can also generate
those links
dynamically, right?
Because if you have a series
of GIDs, you can
just spit them out.
WOLFF: Yes.
But yest, please, feel free
to use our graphics.
JONATHAN: Great.
Well, I want to thank
Gerwin and Siegfried
for joining us today.
Thanks for all the questions
and hanging out with us.
Till next time, I guess.
WOLFF: Yeah, we'll see
you next week.
JONATHAN: Thanks, guys.
WOLFF: Thanks all.
SIEGFRIED: Bye.